so president trump will be taking the
podium at any minute wonder where he's
going to take it to
but in the meantime it's true people who
use social media the most are the worst
people
in the universe a new study tracking
snapchat and facebook use
found that the heaviest users tend to
enjoy upsetting and embarrassing other
people
and are motivated by cruelty and
personal gain
sounds about right when i get off social
media i rarely
feel better than i did when i got on it
perhaps it's because we not only run
into creeps more frequently there
we also can't control the encounters or
maybe i'm the creep
i do believe i'm a better person here
than there which is hard to believe
which leads to the good news the outside
world is indeed a better place
than the net well except portland but in
general all people are better here than
online
plus far more of them are wearing
clothes we do ourselves no good to think
twitter reflects planet earth
look at what happens to the idiots who
do politicians view twitter as an
instant poll
if they see extremism online they move
there twitter becomes their gps
the media does the same thing it's the
new york times entire profit model
today's tweet by a pink haired nut
becomes tomorrow's editorial
and young minds find themselves more
affected by opinions of online strangers
than their loving parents
maybe that's why so many young unstable
unemployed adults find
joy in destroying property communities
careers
lives and ultimately themselves they get
a they get a head start online
then on the street they letter in
vandalism and arson
of course suggesting you should avoid
social media doesn't mean it will avoid
you
turning it off doesn't make the mob
disappear if everyone else including
your employer
takes them seriously until that stops
we're totally screwed
all right we got to be super brief do
you believe this study jessie
i do and i can tell you right now that
every time i go on twitter i only find
out that trump's either senile
racist evil doesn't believe in science
and wants to kill your children
um or that like kamala's face looks
different like or kanye might have said
something
bananas like that's the only really
thing that's good for i check it once in
the morning
and then i check it right at six o'clock
to see if i've said anything
controversial
that i need to apologize for
that's all it is really uh shannon it's
to see if you're going to be canceled
it's a cancel thermometer right